this is Putin's War seven months on
[Music]
I've been looking at this map every day
tracking this war this war that has led
to seven million people fleeing this
country thousands dead including
countless civilians I want to show you
what's going on kind of in the macro a
time lapse of this war
and I also want to look at my
predictions back at the beginning of the
war Russian invasion of Ukraine what I
thought this map might look like and I
want to compare it to how it's actually
played out I've been watching the video
I made from right before the invasion
remembering a world where this hadn't
happened yet I'm not sure that he's
going to invade tomorrow but he very
well could so let me quickly get you up
to speed on what seven months of War has
meant for Ukraine to show you what the
new strategy is for Russia and who's
actually winning this conflict Russian
troops are moving it up
[Music]
hey pause really quick I need to thank
today's sponsor and I'm quite excited
actually because today's sponsor is
climate power there's a big thing
happening in our country right now which
is that a new law was passed that is
like the biggest most significant
climate impact law that is now the law
of the land it actually passed it's a
huge deal and the reason why it passed
in part is because of the pressure from
young people young people who are going
to inherit this Earth are taking serious
action to fight climate change luckily
this is just the beginning climate power
is an organization that makes it very
easy for you to find out how to vote
there are over 8 million new young
voters eligible for this midterm that's
coming up and most of them will not vote
just like based on the data so please
prove the data wrong make a plan to vote
if you don't have one Most states have
like early voting it's actually very
doable and it feels really good like it
feels really good to vote and know that
you're actually like fighting for a
change climate power isn't selling you
anything let literally it is there to
make it super easy to register to vote
to find your polling places to learn how
to vote early if you want to do that so
you don't have to go to a polling place
in short it makes it easier for you to
have your voice heard as a young person
who probably won't vote there are a lot
of candidates running who don't care
about climate change you don't think
it's a real problem and that's why this
is important it is so important that
climate power is sponsoring today's
video and I am so on board with that so
thank you climate power for sponsoring
this video and supporting my channel but
seriously the passage of the inflation
production Act is the beginning we have
momentum let's keep it up so go to
votefuture.org to quickly register to
vote and to find out what you can do to
really affect the selection and check
the links in my description that bring
you to climate power where you can learn
more about what you can do to actually
have your voice heard okay let's get
back to another very important Global
issue the war in Ukraine
okay quick reminder that this Invasion
that happened in February was really
just an escalation of a war that's been
going on over here in the eastern part
of Ukraine for eight the Russian
military now being directly involved in
fighting Ukrainian government foreign
[Music]
it was back in 2014 that Putin invaded
and occupied and then Annex which
basically just means stole this
peninsula called Crimea that sparked a
war that has been going on in this
region the dumbass region for eight
years where ukrainians who sympathize
with Russia rose up trying to fight to
become a part of Russia
and then as we all know earlier this
year I mean you know what happened
Putin moved in from all sides except for
the west of course his big goal was to
swiftly take the capital of Kiev you got
to take the capital if you want to win a
war quickly the scariest images at the
beginning of the war if you remember
were these 60 kilometer long convoys of
Russian military vehicles in these huge
lines moving towards the capital 60
kilometers long I mean these images were
so striking I frankly thought Putin was
going to be victorious in this I thought
he was going to take the capital but
this plan very much did not work we are
seeing the Russians slowly getting
closer to kill Ukrainian forces are
continuing to hold their from the
Russians this was Putin's first big
miscalculation he way overestimated his
troops ability and way underestimated
the response of ukrainians and the West
who pumped loads of weapons into the
country to help them fight not only did
the Russian army fail to take Keys the
Ukrainian Army mounted a very effective
counter-offensive and pushed Russia out
of all of this territory in the course
of just a few weeks after this giant
defeat Putin calls all of his troops
back to regroup and to focus on a more
narrow front of the war
sticking to over here the plan was now
to continue to liberate the Eastern
regions of the country that already had
a lot of pro-russian separatists who
again had been fighting here for eight
years and as the summer approached I
think this is where a lot of us like
started to tune out because the war
turned into a long protracted stalemate
with some occasional Russian gains and a
few counter-offensive from the
ukrainians the term we need to use here
is war of attrition basically who can
wear down the other first through
destruction and endurance this is a
horrible way to fight a war and while
Putin's attempt to take over Kiev failed
he didn't fail in taking over other
major population centers
like here in kirsan which was the first
major city to fall to Russia after the
invasion in the battle for her son in
particular is intensifying
watching how they treat their first
conquered city is a really good
indicator of what Russia's real goal is
here they didn't just occupy the city
they got busy turning it into Russia
they took down the Ukrainian flag and
replaced it with a Russian one they put
up these creepy billboards with like
young children about Russia being one
people and Russia is quote here forever
like super on the nose on what they're
trying to do the brave people of Pearson
gathered and protested like right next
to Russian tanks but that didn't stop
the Russians from doing what they
clearly had been planning this whole
time on May 1st Russia announced that
these people would start using the
Russian Ruble like the Russian currency
They seized control of the broadcasting
and internet channels and stopped these
people from being able to connect with
the world these events are a big deal
because Putin said he was invading to
liberate these people a special military
operation not to conquer them Putin was
unable to oust the government and
initiate a regime change to put in a
government that would have been more
friendly to Russia so now it looks like
he's gonna try to gobble up the country
from the East piece by piece and the key
word here is annex
has launched an intense ground campaign
to capture a key Korean City in the
Eastern Don boss region Annex is a super
benign like technical word but it means
to conquer land to then occupy it and
then to just unilaterally declare that
this land is a part of our Sovereign
territory no treaties no nothing just a
unilateral land grab so let's rewind to
the beginning of the war watch how at
the beginning it was all about this
Invasion from all three sides a very
aggressive Invasion again with the focus
on the capital but once Russia got
kicked out of keys the war really starts
to become focused on all of this but
Russia made progress they took over all
of these population centers here in the
donbass region and by the end of April
it was starting to become clear what the
next move was it came out in Russian
media in this report that a senior
Russian military official said that the
next phase of the operation was quote to
establish full control over the dambas
and Southern Ukraine regions
[Music]
and then he says it Point Blank he says
that this will allow Russia to establish
a land bridge from Mainland Russia all
the way to Crimea this peninsula that
Russia annexed in 2014 but why stop
there this Russian military commander
then infers that the next part of the
plan is to create that land bridge even
further all the way to transnistria this
little sliver of a pretend country that
basically no one recognizes and that
should be a part of Moldova but that is
full of Russian soldiers and a bunch of
people who want Russia to Annex them
establishing this part of the land
bridge would be pretty difficult because
it would mean a battle in Odessa which
is Ukraine's third largest city there'd
be a horrible fight so let's just hope
that part of the plan does not come to
fruition but Russia has been successful
in deeply establishing this land bridge
between their country and Crimea but to
do that they had to fight a very bloody
battle in the port city of mariopol We
Begin tonight with the battle for Mario
the mayor of Mary evil is calling on
residents to evacuate after an egregious
few weeks Russia finally took over the
city thousands of civilians remain in
Maryland so yeah that's the phase of the
war that we are in right now more and
more evidence is mounting that Russia
isn't just planning to occupy and
liberate these people but to actually
Annex them to be a part of Russia U.S
intelligence reports claim that Russia
is installing Russian officials to lead
these cities and Regions they're
creating these fast tracks for Russian
citizenship and making it so that all
new babies born in these regions are
automatically Russian citizens any day
now they're going to hold fake elections
to gauge if the people want to be
Russian and when you look at the results
you're going to see that somehow a
ridiculously giant number of people
voted yes this is their annexation
Playbook they've done it before and it's
worked and it looks like they're doing
it again annexation by force would be a
gross violation of the U.N Charter and
we will not allow it to go unchallenged
or unpunished but the ukrainians are
fighting back they have not surrendered
to this Army that is way more powerful
than they are as we're making this video
there is a giant counter-offensive
happening up here
and the Ukrainian Army is taking back
huge swaths of land the New York Times
pointed out that Ukraine captured more
territory in a week than Russia had
captured in five months and if you watch
the videos of the Ukrainian soldiers
liberating these cities it's pretty
emotional and if we're looking at the
map thinking strategically it's an
important reminder of what the
spokesperson of the U.S National
Security Council said and we would
remind Mr Putin that over time may prove
unable to hold this territory and this
gets to the last point I want to make
here I'm here to argue that he's already
lost back at the beginning of this War I
made this prediction thinking that Putin
was going to be successful in taking the
capital and overthrowing the government
all logic pointed that he was capable of
doing that but he clearly did not I was
wrong instead Putin has been able to
control a few strips of land in the East
and the South he's got his land bridge
to Crimea and he may keep going but
again Putin's War the motive and the
goal is based on some pretty giant
delusions she among them that he is
liberating these people who are ready to
come back to the Russian flaw that is
not what is happening and we have seven
months worth of War to prove it
[Music]